[Music]
hey guys it's doin up here today I want
to gut you through a quick and very
effective five minute warm-up which you
should do prior to exercising the first
rule when it comes to exercising is
never skip your warmup ever it is very
important to fully prepare not just your
body but your mind for the work that
awaits you a good warm-up is important
to increase blood flow to your muscles
and to raise your body temperature so
you get your muscles and joints ready
for maximum flexibility in order to
perform each exercise with proper form
to activate the central nervous system
for best results to reduce the risk of
injury and finally to reduce muscle
soreness if you neglect your warmup
you're putting yourself through the risk
of my injury and you may view or not
earlier than it should be
hence affecting your performance and not
achieving the best results so we're just
spending 5 to 10 minutes to fully
prepare your body and mine you will be
able to burn more calories the more
strength push yourself further and
achieve better results so let's do these
five minutes warm-up together there will
be 10 exercises the first five will be
kind of workouts and the next five will
be dynamic structures 30 seconds for
each workout and there will be no rest
in between let's go so I'm going to set
my timer and let's start with the first
workout which is jump rope I will need
to have fun and just imagine you have a
room in your hand so you can choose to
hop side to side or the double hop okay
just have on 30 seconds above each
workout you can even you know just have
and just hop side to side these
exercises are meant to get your body
warmed up okay hop back one good and
just really imagine you have a rope in
your hand and keep hopping you keep
going the next workout is a vacate reach
and twist side to side great now reach
and crunch to your side
okay reach and crunch richness Heights
you can extend your body genuine stretch
out reach and crunch good so we crunch
and feel your Tulsa warm up good and the
next workout jumping jacks keep going
reach and punch to your side pull it
down nice well and it straight into the
classic of jumping jacks jumping jacks
are great because they work and tight on
me and you basically are stretching your
entire body as well keep going
Sarge on only 30 seconds coming up
lateral snaps with ten touch okay good
breathe heavily whoa can you defeat get
so snapped your side cross over and
touch a key step just like cross over
and touch good cross over touch if you
want to make it more challenging you can
add a hop and touch hop and touch okay
so choose your variation good nice keep
going cross and touch and cross cross
key jump by the cottage warm up cross
jet
so just check it out and cross your leg
close it up
good keep coming this is your final
cardio and you will get straight into
stretches starting with lunch and Kuwait
reach good job well I have really
Stephanie coming good
let's get your muscles ready in the top
we're good now lunch with the right side
reach out stretch that left leg reach up
and stretch good so nice deep stretch on
your thighs and also your body nice keep
going
stretch one step a slight stretch your
body do the stretch good few more last
one
keep going and now side lunge step
launch your site through the stretch in
your inner thighs and change sides step
stretch boot back to the center step
stretch okay
take a white step stretch it down back
white step stretch it down
very good keep going stretch not keep
your puppy boy he'll be more and not
injured
so step to your side and just inch
forward after your hamstrings your legs
stretch out and get the joke
okay rich and give job well done
that was five minutes of really quick
and effective warmup
so you should feel your muscles warmed
up and you should be sweating slightly
if you need a little warm-up session
especially if you are doing intense
training then increase each workout to
one minute long beginners if this is a
challenge don't worry
adapt the exercises so that you can
complete it take it one step at a time
push yourself a little further the next
session and remember do not ever skip
your warmup no excuses are the best for
new fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website
do you follow me on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter to stay connected with me
thanks guys
[Music]
you